are you excited for project Scorpio well
we've already learned about the new
consoles impressive specs and now
Microsoft has said it wants to rebuild
its relationship with developers I'm
Matt and this gamespot news update is
all about Microsoft and it's consoles
speaking to Eurogamer Xbox corporate
vice president Mike ibarra said the team
looked back at developers and a
developer relationship we have with xbox
360 we had the absolute best platform
for developers with Xbox one we sort of
lost that in a two year time frame so we
said how do we win the mind share of
those developers back we want the best
games running on our box and there are
tools dev kits and some arrows like that
to win the developers back ibarra added
that Microsoft has been focused on
ensuring that developers have a toolset
that allows them to create the absolute
best version of their games project
Scorpio specs were recently revealed by
digital foundry who were shown a forza
motorsport demo running at 60 frames per
second in native 4k however it's worth
noting that the graphics settings were
equivalent to what we've seen on the
Xbox one and other games are likely to
vary in frame rate and resolution
there's sure to be a lot more Scorpio
news in the future so make sure to LIKE
and subscribe to stay up-to-date on that
but if you want to see a game you can
play on your xbox one as soon as next
week check out our video review of
ukulele
[Music]
you